well I was at Justin and Hayley's
wedding Oh were you and how was that
though it was actually really super
awesome they're an adorable couple you
know when they were dating I wasn't
really around that much until until the
last like you know a little bit before
they got married and I've had the
pleasure of being around them and the
wedding was really super sweet I was
surprised it's kind of come across the
wrong way but I was surprised because it
was really normal and super
family-oriented and you could really
feel how palpable the love in the room
that they had for one another and my
wedding was like just my family alone
turned it into like a Hollywood sort of
pimp fest you know and I try to keep it
grounded and rooted in family and oh I
wish I had my phone I've got this super
trippy picture of me and Usher oh we did
a photo booth thing with Justin and
Hayley and I have to give it to you by
the time this you're gonna get you're
gonna have let me show you it's a really
cool picture of me and the photo booth
with Usher and Justin and Hayley because
Justin is like your son-in-law
technically right he's not my son Steven
he's my nephew and long okay it's
married to my niece and my nephew WA and
but the wedding was really really super
cool really sweet very normal very
rooted in you know I got to meet a lot
of Justin's family and they're all up
from like Stratford and Kitchener and
everything and you know a lot of a lot
of very climate like a hundred aunts and
uncles and stuff and everybody's you
know intermingle and everybody got along
really well of course you're standing
there saying all this and all of a
sudden you know kendall Jenner walks by
or you know uh sure was there there was
some pretty cool friends at there I mean
legitimate friends these are the people
that like discovered Justin and helped
launch his career and it was a young boy
I think Hailey and regale you know they
were they was beautiful her wedding was
her wedding gown was cool cuz out of
this long trail and woven into the end
of the trail it said till death do us
part
like stitched it to the pilot I thought
that was really kind of edgy and cool
for her to do that you guys had a good
time yeah it was in South Carolina at
this really cool montage property called
palmetto Bluffs never been there before
21 thousand acres the property I'm told
the property is bigger than Manhattan
it's bigger than they own meant 20
thousand acres they got everything there
but really cool and I'm looking forward
to to getting to know him better I've
been around him a few times he's been
such a sweetheart and as you know I had
a family member one of my children was
recently ill last year and he all of my
family really really you know rallied
around the situation with my son and
Justin was really sweet about it - there
was a couple times where he got a chance
to show up for him when he was going
through his treatments and he was going
through his different procedures and
stuff and he you know said a couple
beautiful prayers that's nice and he
noticed that you on October 30 posted a
picture of your son and you didn't talk
about him much Jordan ever really talked
about why it was important for you to
put it out there well I didn't he did I
took a picture that he put it and once
he put it out my brothers and sisters
and cousins all started texting him
saying I just saw that congratulations
privately texting him but then they
started commenting on his post and then
my brother Alec reposted his posts and
then I said him do you mind if I you
know it's it's you put it out there it's
out there and then I put it out there
and I wasn't sort of you know
Entertainment Tonight in Access
Hollywood and USA Today and People
magazine and the New York Post and it I
don't think my son was I said this is
brace yourself dude this is your life
this is what's gonna happen because
you're in it I mean think about my son's
Hollywood family tree his father's Billy
Baldwin
his mother is China Phillips Wilson
Phillips the Baldwin brothers his uncle
is Alec Baldwin and Stephen Baldwin his
cousin is Haley Bieber her husband is
Justin Bieber
you know his cousins Ireland Ireland's
mother is Kim Basinger Bijou China
sister be she was married to Danny
Masterson I mean this is like all of
their aunts and uncles so they're
they're sort of Hollywood family tree
even if they wanted to China and I avoid
Hollywood at all cost because you know
we get enough of it just you know
everyday just dealing with all the
family yes it took me a while because
watching your post and he wrote hashtag
keep her head up and hash tag F
cancer and he hit me be some a mother as
well right and I can't even fathom the
idea that you learned that your son has
cancer
I mean being part of this rally being
part of this foundation was somewhat of
a coping mechanism for you in China it
was it was weird you always you you you
never you know you never like I've come
to these events for sick kids here this
is for for pinball this time the car
rallies for pinball Clemons foundation
but I've been here for a rally for sick
kids many times and I've made
connections with some of the kids Jaden
and Eloise and it made some real
connections and stayed in touch with
some of the families and still I'm in
touch with the families last time I was
in town I had breakfast with Eloise's
mom and dad and it's just not the same
until and that we did the boat rally up
in Muskoka and when Joel Hawk who runs
solutions with impact that produces all
of these events said I'd like to have
Billy come up here in that part of the
program will you sell yourself to get to
get dressed and he said by the way he's
become a member of the family I wasn't
ready for I didn't know he was gonna do
that and nobody knew it separates a
group of people in my community in Santa
Barbara for the whole year
and I'd met Matt and then he said Billy
is now you know officially become a
member of the family his son was
diagnosed with cancer and I got up there
to try so myself and I lost it because
I've been surrounded by these people who
have been raising money millions of
dollars and really care about this this
this gem that you have in your community
Sick Kids Hospital and I've been around
these families and I I really feel I
really feel what they're going through
and I when I hold them I can't imagine
what it's like to be the parent of a
child that's going through something
like that and then all of a sudden I was
a parent of a child I was going through
something like that and it was it was
yeah you just you know you're never
gonna know you're never gonna know yeah
you're never gonna know haven't killed
India two girls two guys you're never
gonna know I was very lucky because my
son had you know very dangerous
situation advanced
cancer but he had a kept type of cancer
that responds very if you like were to
spin the wheel you would hope that this
is the cancer that I would land on like
you would hope that that because it
responds very very well that came on I'm
happy to tell you that he's his his
scans are clear and his tumor markers
are in normal ranges but that's the the
new game what I learned a little
expression that I learned here called
scan xiety okay and that's what you now
live with us you know we'll go on
forever if you you won't have to do
scans ten years from now but the first
couple years after he's considered
they've got everything under control
you've got to do bloodwork every month
and you kind of do scans every couple of
months for we've got a little ways to go
does the revision he's a high school
senior and he's back on the basketball
team I've really big beautiful kid he's
almost six five and his high school
basketball team is there animals there
they were like 30 30 wins in like five
losses last year so he's really excited
to finish out his last year and try to
win the what's called the CIF in
California is a big deal to win the CIF
he wants to do that this year
you